THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARE WELL WE
HAVE A QUORUM.
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
QUIRK.
HERE QUIRK IS HERE MELENDEZ
MULLIN DOES IS HERE ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
OUR KEY HANDS HERE DOLLY.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HERE HOLDEN.
MATHIS MATHIS IS HERE.
MURATSUCHI.
WE HAVE FIVE MEMBERS WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
MOVED.
WE HAVE. TWO BILLS ON CONSENT.
SB TWO THIRTY TWO DODD AND SB
[inaudible]
FIVE FIFTY TWO ARCHULETA.
AND YES COME ON OUT.
AND THEN -- IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
MEMBER GARCIA SECOND BY MEMBER
MATHIS -- CAN WE ACT MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM ONE SB TWO THIRTY TWO DODD
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FIVE FIVE
TWO ARE TO LET THEM THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION CONSENT.
QUIRK.
HI QUIRK HI MELENDEZ MULLIN
DESAI ARAMBULA.
OUR CAN BARKING AND ME.
DALY.
CRISTINA GARCIA THE SENIOR CI
HOLDEN.
MATHIS.
BY MATHIS AYE.
WHAT A TO G.?
BECAUSE WE HAVE FIVE VOTES IN
THE CALENDAR IS OUT [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
SENATOR RUBIO -- PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR WONDERFUL BILL.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING OUT.
IT'S MOVED BY A MEMBER MATHIS
AND DWIGHT HERE SECOND BY.
MEMBER GARCIA [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COME AND PRESENT
TODAY AND THAT THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WOULD JUST KIND HOUSE FOR
YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
SIR.
IF YOU'VE STAFF FOR YOU AT
EXPERT WITNESS HE WAS HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTION I AM A GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M READY STROLLER MEN
FROM THE SAME GIVER BASIN WATER
QUALITY AUTHORITY -- WERE THE
AGENCY.
THAT IS BEING AFFECTED BY THE
BILL AND IS HERE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU RIGHT.
THE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MEMBERS IN THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU -- GOOD.
HELLO CHRISTY FOR ON BEHALF OF
THE THREE VALLEY'S MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS GENOCIDE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER COALITION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON GAME ROMAN R. IS
ON THE OFFICE AND GIVE A VALLEY
WATER COMPANY IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO COME IN.
CENTER FRONT OF YOU AND AGAIN
KILEY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
YES SO.
THIS IS A GREAT BILL IT -- MAKES
THE COMMITTEE MORE EFFICIENT.
AND IT'S DOING GREAT WORK AND
I'M VERY GLAD YOU BROUGHT THE
BILL FORWARD MADAM SECRETARY.
WHAT IS THE MOTION AND PLEASE
CALL THEN CALL THE ROLL?
SHE THERE WAS ONE AMENDMENT IT'S
FROM THE WATER BOARD -- THEY
ASKED -- FOR IF I MANAGE BEST
SAID MAN.
YES JUST REALLY QUICKLY AND I
APOLOGIZE AND ALL THAT WANTED TO
EXPEDITE THIS FOR FOR YOUR
PURPOSE BUT WE HAVE HAPPILY
TAKEN THE TECHNICAL COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS AT NEW WILL BE
MAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU FOR IF YOU'RE A THAT WAS
SUGGESTION FROM THE WATER BOARD.
AND ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HERE HAVE SEEN THAT IN THE
ANALYSIS [inaudible]
OUR IT'S IN THE ANALYSIS WE WANT
DISCUSS SOMEONE WANT TO READ IT.
YEAH WILL PASS THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENT -- DO YOU WANT SOMEONE
TO READ THE AMENDMENT.
OKAY SO IT'S BEING ARE AMENDED
HEARING COMMITTEE AND THAT'S
JUST AS IS HAVE A SMALL CHANGE.
ALL RIGHT NOW YOU MAY READ THE
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO SB FOUR THIRTEEN SUSAN.
SUSAN RUBIO THE MOTION IS DO
PASSES AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
QUIRK.
HI QUIRK HI MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
HI ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA A POWER CAN.
ARCADIA HI DOLLY.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I HOLDEN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I WOULD A TO G.
[inaudible] SIX ZERO TO THE TOP.
YOUR TUITION RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
RIGHT I AM AT THE DOCTOR
RAMBLING CAN WE ADD YOU TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY -- THE
OTHER WE GONNA STAY OPEN TILL
ONE FORTY FIVE WHICH IS FIVE
MINUTES ON THE CLOCK BACK THERE --
FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
HE SAID I HEAR AND THAT.
WHAT SHOULD WE DO WHAT'S WRONG
?
THIS IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
THAT TAKES A TWO SIX ZERO AND
THAT WAS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
NOW WE'RE DOING ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS SB FOUR THIRTEEN SUSAN
RUBIO.
THE VOTE IS AT SIX ZERO HOLDEN.
WELL TONIGHT
-- THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE VOTE
STANDS AT SIX ZERO MURATSUCHI.
WHAT'S A GI.
BRING THAT.
TO SEVEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER TWO US
BEFORE THIRTEEN SUSAN RUBIO --
THE VOTE IS AT SEVEN ZERO WHAT
CITY WHAT CITY I THANK YOU
.
BUT I WILL -- JUST.
I CAN RUN [inaudible]
WE WERE [inaudible]
SORRY.
YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH.
I LOST TRACK.
THANK.
THANK YOU. FOR FLOOR AND WHAT'S
GOING [inaudible]
TO OKAY [inaudible]
YOUR QUESTION [inaudible]
EACH VOTE [inaudible] TO
DISTRACT [inaudible] FOR IF YOU
CALL THE HEAD.
THANKS TO THE SPIDERS
[inaudible]
WHY WHO?
SERVICES YEARS ON BECAUSE OF
THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH
.
YEAH.
JUST NOT.
YEAH WE WE HAVE TO DO A DOT DOT
NINE CROSS CITY.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
VOTE STANDS AT SEVEN ZERO
ARAMBULA.
CONSENT CALENDAR SIX ZERO YOU
HAVE RECORDED HIS VOTE YET I
WHEN I WAS SEVEN ZERO I'M THERE
ARE THERE OKAY.
YEAH I DID I DO THE EARTH EVENTS
THERE ARE IT'S OKAY. SEVEN ZERO
I DON'T WANT.
I DON'T BELIE TAKES IT TO A TEAR
THANK YOU THANKS TO DATE THANK
YOU.
OF WE ARE ADJOURNED